Générique
...
Ils chantent en choeur
"Aux légionnaires".
Mais ça n'est pas admis chez nous
Un copain dit au bord d'not'trou
Quelqu'bout d'prière
Deux morceaux d'bois
en croix, un nom
Qu'importe si c'nom là
c'est pas l'bon
C't'un légionnaire
Applaudissements
...
-Il y a des rendez-vous
à ne pas manquer.
Dans les coulisses de l'Olympia,
la Musique de la Légion étrangère
se prépare à un concert qui fera
date. De Jacques Brel
à Lady Gaga, en passant
par les Rolling Stones,
les plus grands artistes
se sont produits ici.
Ce jour-là,
c'est au tour des légionnaires.
La Musique de la Légion étrangère
fait partie des 11 formations
musicales professionnelles
du ministère des Armées.
Originale à plus d'un titre,
dont la particularité
de son recrutement.
-Ce sont des légionnaires
qui ont suivi le même parcours,
la même démarche
de 9000 autres.
La seule différence est qu'ils sont
doués, ils ont un don
soit parce qu'ils l'ont découvert
soit parce que
c'était des professionnels
dans leur pays d'origine
pour la musique.
Ils ont des qualités
qu'on détecte parfois très tôt
ou que le chef de musique
détecte après.
Ce sont de vrais légionnaires,
qui font des périodes
d'entraînement, des missions
Sentinelle.
-Certains ont même servi plusieurs
années en unité opérationnelle.
-Sur 60 musiciens,
j'ai aujourd'hui 17 nationalités,
des parcours
complètement atypiques, des gens
qui quittent leurs familles,
leurs pays, leurs racines,
donc ils arrivent là, il faut
s'en occuper, il faut être avec eux.
Ca, c'est inestimable.
On les perçoit.
On va chercher la sensibilité.
A travers la musique,
c'est pareil. Quand on chante,
on distingue tous les timbres de
voix par rapport aux nationalités.
Et quand ils s'expriment
en chantant ou en jouant,
c'est leurs tripes qui sortent.
Voilà, ils ont cette fierté
d'appartenir à la Légion.
Je dis, c'est pas la meilleure
musique, mais c'est la plus belle.
Ouvrez la bouche.
Ils chantent en choeur "La Colonne".
-La tête de la colonne est formée
-Une exception humaine
qui se retrouve
autour d'un langage
universel, la musique.
Depuis la création
de la Légion étrangère
en 1831, ces artistes militaires
font rayonner
un précieux patrimoine musical.
Habitués aux représentations
de prestige, ils vont cette fois
récolter des fonds pour les anciens,
les blessés et leurs familles.
Un nouveau défi pour ces hommes
habitués à en relever et à quelques
minutes d'entrer en scène,
les coeurs s'emballent.
-Du courage, il en faudra.
Ils sont très attendus.
Mélomanes, fans de la Légion, venus
entre amis ou en famille,
ils ont parfois fait
des centaines de kilomètres
pour assister à ce concert.
Pendant 2h,
les képis blancs vont offrir
le spectacle de leur vie en alliant
répertoire militaire
et chansons populaires.
Sur cette scène légendaire,
ils vont raconter
instruments à la main l'épopée
de M. Légionnaire,
de son engagement
à sa formation militaire...
Percussions
...
Sans oublier ses coups de blues
avec une interprétation
bouleversante d'un extrait
de la bande originale
de "La liste de Schindler".
...
Puis il y a les permissions à Paris,
bercées par Edith Piaf.
Un moment suspendu
que les musiciens partagent
avec la chanteuse Nathalie Lermitte.
-Qui mettait dans ses cheveux blonds
De la lumière
Applaudissements
...
-Ce soir,
les légionnaires osent tout,
jusqu'à un rap audacieux
qui reprend un thème très connu.
Il rappe.
...
Applaudissements
-Un final en apothéose
pour ces musiciens et leur chef
qui clôture sa carrière
après 43 ans sous les drapeaux.
La musique militaire n'a pas
toujours été en haut de l'affiche.
Pour le comprendre,
il faut remonter le temps.
D'abord genre musical,
elle est progressivement devenue
aussi une formation instrumentale.
-La musique militaire
a servi de tout temps
à transmettre des ordres,
d'abord sur les champs
de bataille bien sûr,
mais aussi dans la vie
aux quartiers entre guillemets,
par des batteries, des sonneries.
Au fur et à mesure sont nées
des formations militaires
dans la Renaissance.
Après l'époque de Louis XIV
où les orchestres se structurent,
c'est essentiellement
à la Révolution française
que les musiques militaires
prennent leur essor
avec la création
de l'Institut national
de Musique, fondé pour former
les musiciens militaires.
On a eu jusqu'à une dizaine
de classes de clarinette, de basson,
d'instruments à vent
au Conservatoire de Paris.
Au 19e siècle,
c'est l'apport des instruments
d'Adolphe Sax, un facteur belge.
Il fait évoluer
les orchestres militaires
avec les saxophones et les saxhorns.
Ils vont considérablement développer
le son de ces ensembles militaires,
des orchestres.
Pendant la Première Guerre mondiale,
les musiciens militaires
sont utilisés souvent comme aides
au service médical, brancardiers.
Et puis sont utilisés évidemment
comme emploi de cérémonial
et également et surtout comme outil
de soutien du moral des troupes.
La musique militaire est
un outil du passé
qui transmet un répertoire,
une histoire, des tenues
et qui également est tourné
vers l'avenir,
la musique d'aujourd'hui,
des musiques modernes,
des musiques récentes,
comme les musiques militaires
l'ont toujours fait.
-Vecteur de mobilisation au combat,
de prestige, puis de divertissement,
la place de la musique n'a cessé
d'évoluer, une diversité d'emplois
qui continue de séduire.
Chaque année, des dizaines
de musiciens professionnels
sont sélectionnés
pour intégrer
les formations militaires.
Comme Victor, 28 ans. Il a rejoint
la Musique des Parachutistes
de Toulouse,
l'ambassadrice des troupes
aéroportées de l'armée de terre.
Musicien depuis l'âge de 8 ans
et ancien élève du Conservatoire
du Havre, il est aujourd'hui
militaire du rang. Il se souvient
de cette audition très sélective
pour vivre de sa passion,
la clarinette.
-Ca se fait d'abord
par l'avis de concours
auquel on doit répondre,
envoyer un dossier
avec CV, lettre de motivation.
Et si notre profil peut convenir,
on est invité à passer
un concours musical
et ça, ça se passe en général
en une ou deux étapes.
On arrive ici, on a une phase
de chauffe, préparation,
et on arrive après devant le jury
où on doit jouer une pièce
qu'on a préparée
ou deux, ça dépend
des années de concours,
et un morceau de déchiffrage,
avant d'entamer un entretien
qui a été assez approfondi,
pour savoir si notre profil
peut correspondre.
...
-On est bien contents de voir
de jeunes candidats très dynamiques
et encore dans un cursus d'études
pour amener
à la fois de l'énergie,
de la bonne humeur,
au sein du pupitre en particulier
et plus généralement,
dans l'orchestre.
Comme dans n'importe
quelle entreprise, on a aussi besoin
de cerner les personnes,
savoir ce qu'ils pensent
d'eux-mêmes, comment ils peuvent
se projeter dans notre orchestre,
voilà, on essaie
de connaître un petit peu
notre future nouvelle recrue.
-Pour les diriger,
le lieutenant Mathieu Larrieu,
le chef de musique,
un rôle essentiel
au sein des musiques militaires
puisqu'il dispose
d'une double casquette :
chef d'orchestre
et commandant d'unité.
Choix des morceaux,
gestion du personnel,
préparation des événements,
il veille à l'excellence du groupe.
-On va commencer avec "Celebrate
Rotary" de Peter Graham.
...
Alors, nos activités
au quotidien imposent
de recruter
des musiciens de haut niveau,
puisque nous sommes, depuis
la professionnalisation des armées,
des orchestres à 100 %
professionnels, donc spécialistes.
Ce qui implique que nous passons
l'essentiel de notre temps
à préparer des représentations,
des cérémonies, des concerts,
parfois dans des délais
relativement restreints,
ce qui impose donc d'avoir des
musiciens qui soient très réactifs
et qui aient
un haut niveau de compétences.
Donc notre cible
pour le recrutement, c'est
surtout les conservatoires.
-46 musiciens composent
la Musique des Parachutistes.
Avant de rejoindre l'orchestre,
chacun suit une FGI,
une formation générale initiale
de quelques mois
dans un centre militaire.
-Une hautboïste, une clarinettiste
et un tromboniste ont été retenus
pour cette séquence, voilà.
Comme tout militaire,
on peut être appelé n'importe quand
pour une cérémonie d'accueil
inopinée
du président qui se déplace
juste à côté 2 jours après,
ou des honneurs funèbres aussi,
ça arrive.
C'est vrai qu'un musicien
qui sort du Conservatoire,
on lui apprend
pendant tout son cursus artistique
à sortir des cases, à s'exprimer,
à aller au-delà des cadres,
et arrivés ici
dans l'institution militaire,
on a beaucoup de cadres,
de règles, de hiérarchie.
Donc au début, ça peut
un peu dérouter. Alors, on essaie
que chacun puisse s'épanouir
artistiquement.
On peut avoir un musicien
qui est passionné de hard rock
et qui ne peut pas exprimer
pleinement cette passion
dans la musique militaire,
mais qui va pouvoir l'exprimer
à l'extérieur
dans un autre groupe civil. Le fait
de pouvoir mener une double vie
parfois fait que l'équilibre peut
se trouver assez facilement
et je pense que ça constitue
un avantage assez intéressant
pour les musiciens.
...
-Pour l'instant, ça m'apporte
beaucoup de stabilité musicale déjà,
ce qui est important pour
un musicien, surtout en finissant
les études de pouvoir se produire
régulièrement dans une structure,
c'est vraiment important.
On est vraiment
comme entre guillemets n'importe
quels musiciens,
sauf qu'effectivement
on a ce statut militaire
qui nous oblige
à certaines choses, quoi.
...
-Cette rigueur militaire rythme
également le quotidien
de la Musique de l'Air
et de l'Espace. Créée en 1936,
elle est installée
sur la base aérienne 107
de Villacoublay près de Paris.
Avec 110 musiciens,
tous lauréats du Conservatoire
national supérieur
de Paris ou de Lyon,
elle est une formation musicale
prestigieuse des armées.
-C'est un orchestre
militaire qui représente
autant que faire se peut
et le plus souvent possible
notre institution
et joue son rôle d'ambassadeur
tant à travers une 1re mission
des cérémonies militaires
et/ou protocolaires,
et ainsi que des concerts soit
caritatifs comme celui de ce soir
soit des concerts
pour les bases aériennes,
des concerts
pour l'autorité militaire
ou dans des festivals de musique.
...
La Musique de l'Air
est un ambassadeur de l'armée
de l'air. Elle se produit
le plus souvent possible
dans des salles de concert,
dans des théâtres comme celui-ci.
Elle se produit le plus souvent
possible pour à la fois divertir,
mais à travers
nos prestations musicales
véhiculer l'image
et les valeurs de l'armée de l'air.
La rigueur des répétitions,
la fréquence des répétitions,
l'exigence artistique
de tous les jours,
nous pensons
que c'est le meilleur moyen
de véhiculer cette image de rigueur
et d'excellence. Notre rôle,
nous, de chef de musique
et d'encadrant avec mes adjoints,
c'est d'entretenir cette exigence,
de la magnifier
et surtout de développer
le travail de cohérence
ou le travail d'ensemble,
la cohésion tout simplement.
...
-Tout musicien, militaire ou non,
travaille à partir du moment
où les gens se détendent.
C'est un choix qui est fait, aussi
avec la vie de famille. C'est aussi
des émotions partagées, des moments
uniques, suspendus des fois.
C'est ce qu'on recherche.
-Cadence caisse en avant, marche !
-L'orchestre militaire accompagne
régulièrement les grandes cérémonies
des aviateurs.
Sur cette place d'armes du sud
de la France, les musiciens
n'ont pas le droit à l'erreur,
tout compte.
Cette représentation millimétrée
illustre un protocole maîtrisé
à la perfection.
-Il y a la cérémonie
de baptême de promotion
des officiers
de l'armée de l'air
et de l'espace à Salon-de-Provence
sur la base aérienne 701.
C'est une cérémonie importante
avant tout pour les jeunes élèves.
Cette cérémonie est présidée par
notre chef, le chef
d'état-major,
le général Stéphane Mille.
-C'est une cérémonie très importante
pour les officiers.
C'est un tournant
dans leur carrière.
Une musique avec des musiciens
apporte une solennité
à ces moments-là
qui est très, très importante.
-Lors des déplacements,
la musique nous aide
à marcher au pas,
à rester synchronisés,
à garder nos alignements,
à garder nos bras tendus
et en somme, elle rythme nos pas.
Et c'est quelque chose
de réellement stimulant.
Et je pense
que la Musique de l'Air rajoute
une dimension autre,
une dimension
vraiment très solennelle
dans notre cérémonie.
...
-Depuis que l'on rentre
en école de formation,
jusqu'à... jusqu'à maintenant
et durant toutes les cérémonies
auxquelles on peut assister,
la musique est présente,
que ce soit à travers les chants,
les chants qui renforcent
la cohésion, qui nous permettent
de marcher correctement
au pas cadencé,
et lors des cérémonies
qui rythment la vie du militaire.
Il y a cet adage
qui veut qu'un bon soldat
est d'abord un beau soldat
et justement,
la musique nous aide à cela.
-Comme toute prestation,
il y a toute une préparation
technique, musicale donc,
avec du travail séquencé
par pupitre ou par groupe,
du travail en répétition générale,
les mouvements aussi,
puisque, quand on se déplace,
ça nécessite beaucoup de rigueur.
C'est décuplé,
c'est encore plus difficile
lorsqu'on est en nocturne, donc
sans trop de repères visuels.
Les marches militaires
ont ceci de particulier,
la structure de la marche
tant sur le plan rythmique
que sur le plan des mélodies,
c'est quelque chose
de très symétrique
et donc qui permet les déplacements.
-Protocole et cérémonies
ne représentent
qu'une partie du quotidien
de ces musiciens.
La musique militaire sait aussi
être festive
et populaire.
...
En Normandie,
le bagad de Lann-Bihoué donne
l'aubade à l'Armada de Rouen.
Cette fête réunit
tous les 4 à 6 ans pendant 10 jours
une quarantaine de voiliers et de
bâtiments militaires
français et étrangers.
Difficile de le rater,
sa musique joyeuse rassemble
aussitôt du monde.
-On était venus déjà en 2019,
c'était des supers souvenirs
d'ailleurs.
Les rencontres, les bateaux,
il y a beaucoup de choses.
C'est un bouillon de culture.
On est hyper contents de revenir.
On a des souvenirs qu'on commence
à se remémorer
quand on arrive sur le site.
C'est hyper chouette.
...
-Le quartier-maître dirige
depuis près de 2 ans cet ensemble
de musique traditionnelle bretonne,
issu de la Marine nationale.
Son titre : penn soner en breton,
autrement dit, chef d'orchestre.
-C'est une chance quelque part
d'être responsable
de musiciens qui sont incroyables.
On s'entend super bien.
C'est une super expérience.
C'est génial, vraiment.
Applaudissements
-Le bagad compte
30 musiciens professionnels,
des soners,
parmi lesquels des joueurs
de bombarde, de cornemuse,
de caisse claire et de percussions.
Militaires, ils signent
un contrat d'un an
avec la Marine nationale,
renouvelable 4 fois.
Age limite, 30 ans.
Moyenne d'âge, 24.
Joueuse de caisse claire
depuis l'âge de 8 ans,
le matelot Youna a choisi
d'auditionner au bagad
après ses études.
C'est sa 1re année.
-Depuis mai, on enchaîne.
Vraiment le rythme de l'été
est arrivé,
entre les festivals ou les voyages
qu'on a pu faire à l'étranger.
Donc on est partis aux Etats-Unis
pour un Tattoo militaire à Norfolk,
10 jours, et ensuite, on a eu la
chance d'embarquer sur le Dixmude,
qui est un porte-hélicoptère,
pendant 3 semaines,
pour faire du rayonnement. On a fait
Nouméa, les îles Fidji puis Tahiti.
C'était chouette d'embarquer
comme ça sur un bâtiment militaire.
On est marins,
mais on n'embarque pas,
donc on a vraiment pu voir
comment se passait la vie à bord,
ce que c'était
d'être un marin embarqué finalement.
Et la joie après
d'arriver sur des îles comme ça
pour partager la musique,
c'est quand même
une très belle expérience.
-Pour Youna, le bagad est une
affaire de famille.
Son frère l'a intégré la même année.
Mais à chacun son instrument,
le matelot Gwenaël
joue de la bombarde.
-On joue en famille,
entre frères et soeurs
au sein du bagad, par réel plaisir
de partager ça à deux.
Déjà, le fait de jouer au bagad
de Lann-Bihoué, c'est une expérience
en elle-même, mais le faire à deux,
en famille, c'est
très enrichissant. Chacun
apporte ce qu'il peut
apporter à l'autre
et ça fera des supers souvenirs.
Je considère le fait
d'intégrer le bagad
comme un accomplissement musical.
Quand on commence
la musique tout petit,
on rêve de devenir professionnel.
C'est la continuité
de tout mon cursus,
du conservatoire
et enfin le bagad de Lann-Bihoué.
On a un côté traditionnel
de par les instruments qu'on utilise
et les airs qu'on joue. Après,
on est ouverts sur les autres styles
de musique. Dans nos concerts,
on intègre du piano,
de la trompette,
du saxophone, de la guitare basse.
Et les compositions des musiciens
du groupe sont très influencées
par toutes les musiques actuelles.
-L'aventure du bagad démarre en 1952
sur la base d'aéronautique navale
de Lann-Bihoué,
près de Lorient.
-A l'origine, un maître principal
a sorti une bombarde de sa poche
et a commencé à jouer un air breton.
Petit à petit,
d'autres musiciens l'ont rejoint
et c'est ainsi
que s'est créé le bagad.
...
Etre à la tête du bagad,
c'est enrichissant humainement,
c'est valorisant,
c'est une aventure extraordinaire,
une aventure humaine extraordinaire.
Et puis, c'est aussi une découverte,
même si je suis bretonne,
j'ai quand même appris malgré tout
plein de choses.
Ce que fait le bagad,
c'est une musique populaire.
Les gens viennent
facilement vers les jeunes,
peut-être parce qu'ils sont jeunes,
et les musiciens
se prêtent beaucoup à cela.
Ils aiment parler de leur musique,
expliquer ce qu'ils font.
Ils aiment beaucoup
être en prestation et avoir
cette possibilité de répondre
aux questions après une prestation.
-C'est très agréable,
parce qu'on a le contact directement
avec le public.
Dès qu'ils entendent de la musique,
les gens reviennent nous écouter.
Il y a un rapport qui n'est pas
forcément dans une salle
où on est sur scène, il y a plus
de distance avec les spectateurs.
Là, on est au sein de la foule,
au sein de l'Armada,
on sent que les gens sont contents
qu'on soit là.
...
Applaudissements
-La musique est bien rythmée.
C'est joli comme musique.
Les costumes sont beaux.
C'est la 1re fois que je viens
et avec la musique,
c'est merveilleux.
-Ca met une bonne ambiance.
C'est agréable.
C'est plus agréable
que les enceintes
et la musique actuelle.
-Cool. Il y a de tout.
Il y a la cornemuse,
il y a de la clarinette,
je suppose,
ça change.
Il y a de la musique bretonne.
C'est nos voisins,
c'est les Bretons.
-Ca interpelle, ça donne envie
de s'arrêter. C'est agréable.
-Vous connaissiez le bagad ?
-Oui, on les a vus
à la dernière Armada,
c'était super bien.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...